i'm just curious what would your advice
be to like you know
young artists and signing record labels
[ __ ] the label do you think
independence right or get with an
independent label
at least don't don't sign
for money obviously don't time for money
sign for resources yeah you know
if that's just if you don't have i mean
it's so easy to
put out a song now it's just you just
you can make a song on your phone and
then post it to the internet from your
phone yeah no you know
right no it's not definitely not the big
ones favorite
yeah for real not the big ones like it's
it's a lot of dope independent labels
out here that can actually facilitate
a real artist and actually have the
resources to get that artist where they
need to be but you know
is it like super necessary if you work
hard enough you'll get you'll get to
where you're going eventually
uh labels just give you that extra push
and make it make the process faster
what is that deal that they have that
even if you leave the
group you got to pay at 360. something
like this
well any deal whoa all the money gotta
come back stop the bus
stop the bus brother stop about that any
any deal
all the money got to come back and but
in particular deals uh
even if you just stop everything like
all you they they start getting assets
and
you know if you ain't making the money
we'll we'll we'll make it work
we'll make it happen they get pretty
[ __ ] bad dude
they get pretty bad i started learning
about bad deals once i got in them
yeah it wasn't that's not it's not like
an apparent thing they're like hey you
want a bunch of money yeah
slavery like these people in your life
you know
yeah so obviously you experienced
something oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
i mean you know most of them got
resolved because i got smart and sober
that's the time no no i unless the lady
will keep up mike do you have anything
to give us
i still have these mansions and cars and
stuff and the ladies
i don't know how i kept all this [ __ ] i
just don't know how i thought
really and then i guess eventually um
they died or something or something
i couldn't i couldn't pay the tax i
can't pay they can't get no money for me
so they
they made it lower and ah yeah [ __ ]
i still can't yeah
but you know how you good to be free you
really actually feel like a slave when
you're under that [ __ ] for real right
that's intense that's worse than whoo
i'm saying why don't you say no
way you're watching football i didn't
know it was like that i don't like
i'm waiting for these people to come
start knocking on the door and all this
this just never gets bigger
[Music]